hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here are three puzzles involving the
following figure
a
remove three sticks to leave three
squares
b
remove three sticks to leave five
squares
c
remove five sticks to leave two squares
can you figure these out
give them a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
let's solve each puzzle in turn
first let's remove three sticks to leave
three squares
we'll remove one two and three
this leaves exactly one two three
squares
now
how can we remove three sticks to leave
five squares we can remove these three
sticks
we have four little squares
and then we have one large square which
makes the fifth square
finally
how can we remove five sticks to leave
two squares
we'll remove these three outer sticks
and then we remove these two on the
inside
we're left with one small square and one
large square
did you figure them out
and did you think of any other solutions
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views let's
share the beauty of mathematics with
your help we can math the world a better
place please subscribe for free to get
the news videos watch and share all of
mine your decisions videos email me a
puzzle presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support